[inaudible].
All right,
so let's shift the discussion a little bit to the NRA because that was the other
part of this,
that during the town hall and the subsequent discussions that it got very
confused as to what the NRA actually does.
What do they want to do?
What are their people who don't like them,
think they do,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
so first off,
just give me your position on the NRA general.
I think the NRA is a fantastic organization that defends the rights,
the right to bear arms of individuals thing with the NRA is that they really
don't have the money influence that people say they do.
All they have is the social influence.
Republican senators know that the base believes in the values of the NRA
promotes and defense and they understand that.
And if they go against the NRA,
they're going against their own constituents.
The NRA does not have a big budget.
They really don't.
They,
they're not like this,
like super powerful like that.
They directly control senators and congressman with their money.
They control it with their ideals.
What the NRA does,
which is fantastic,
is it provides a check from like from the public,
not not from the government for defending our right to bear arms.
And it's fantastic.
And you know,
it helped I think with the case with Mcdonald's versus Chicago that helped
bolster a second amendment rights for individuals.
I mean in the NRA does just does a great job.
They're NRA Ila program,
which is actually the legislative branch on defending the second amendment does
a fantastic job.
I think right now they're taking a case against raising the age from 18 to 21
there was right for the shooting.
Uh,
Rick Scott signed into law in Florida raising the age to buy I think a firearm
rifle now.
So before,
before,
uh,
you couldn't buy a handgun if you're under 21,
but you could buy a rifle because handguns were used in violent crimes.
Whether I think that's right or not,
that's a separate discussion.
But he raised the age from 1821 to buy a rifle and directly the NRA was like,
this is unconstitutional.
Boom.
We put it in a lawsuit just to address that 18 to 21 age.
Uh,
there is absolutely no evidence that raising the age does absolutely does,
does anything to,
uh,
to lower,
um,
gun homicide whatsoever.
So what do you think about the certain set of people that think that if we could
just have all of the right laws or if we could just manage everything properly,
that everything would be fine because it doesn't take into,
do we have
the laws that we need already on the books as thing as the enforcement doesn't
work?
So I'll just make a tangent.
I'll get back to here.
I think it is utterly hypocritical that the left hates Trump and they,
that he's in power,
but then they're saying we have to trust the government more.
So if you think the government,
if you think Trump has literally Hitler,
why are you giving away your right to wear berms to this tyrannical government?
Um,
what was the question again?
Well,
just that there's a certain set of people that think if we just have,
oh yeah,
I got
you.
So we already have the laws on the books,
you know,
just the enforcement is the enforcement of what needs to occur.
Like the Lautenberg amendment,
that domain,
it says that domestic abusers can not have a firearm that's already on the
books.
It just needs to be enforced.
There's the issue with um,
you know,
the nics background check program where they say we need more time to,
to evaluate and give you back your background check in order to buy a weapon.
The issue is the government doesn't need more time,
it just needs more of the records.
So the reason why the Texas soil and shooting occurred was because I think it
was some military brands where there were someone who were,
he,
he committed a violation.
And by law they sh the heat.
They should have transferred that over to the database.
And if we wouldn't have been able to buy a weapon,
but the records weren't transferred,
who was able to buy a weapon and he shot up the church.
So the government just needs to get all the records and do their job.
Same thing with red flag laws.
Um,
and people like to talk about this,
this is a little bit more the trickier areas of this,
but red flag laws,
uh,
basically say that someone can flag you and then you get reviewed and then you
can get your gun taken away.
Uh,
and a lot of people also like,
so the issue with red flag gun laws is that it's all about government
enforcement and,
and that's,
that's,
that's the issue.
And there's also the big issue where people like to talk about mental health and
they say you mentally ill people shouldn't be able to acquire a weapon.
So I have talked to countless individuals about this and I should ask Peterson,
but I forgot to,
the question is how do you determine when someone is mentally ill enough and
hits the threshold so they cannot have a weapon and nobody knows.
And in addition to things with the shooter and my school looking retroactively,
we can say this kid was mentally insane,
but I don't know if a court would adjudicate that.
He would actually be mentally insane by,
by law and therefore taking his gun away.
Yeah.
So is the inherent problem here.
Do you think that you cannot manage all of these things?
You can do the best you can to have some sensible laws around them and defend
our right to bear arms and all of that and make sure schools are taken care of.
But that generally speaking,
yes,
there's a sort of sliding scale psychologically,
but also that the people that want to do bad,
we'll find ways to do bad.
They're not the ones that are walking out and looking at a building and it says,
oh no guns here.
Yes,
I'm not going to walk in with a gun.
Criminals will act like criminals no matter what.
But the good thing is is that our laws are working.
I mean I think it's violent crime or hot.
Some rate from the 1990s to 2010 has decreased by 50% and and pub in schools are
safer now than they were 20 years ago.
Like school shooting rates are declining and homicide rate gun homicide rates
are declining and the homicide rates are declining.
So we are becoming a more peaceful nation.
And a lot of that has to do with having more gun owners and to having more,
you know,
concealed carry permit owners.
Because those people,
when,
when there's a shooting,
those people are the first responders.
I think it's wrong to say that,
oh,
we'll just let the police arrive after the crime has been committed.
No,
you need people there immediately to stop the shooter.
That's why I'm all for teachers and arm school officers at schools to
immediately take down the shooter.
All right,
so let's,
let's shift,
I mean,
I don't think we're going to fully get away from guns here,
but let's shift a little bit.
Okay.
What is it like to be a 17 year old right now that's in the mix of this,
that's now a public person.
It's crazy to just be part of this,
this oddly unique time where it feels like the adults have lost the plot and
it's gotta be very hard for you to find people that kind of make sense.
I think you've been able to find a couple of them,
but just to be 17 in this very odd political cultural time.
Yeah,
it's insane.
It's insane.
What does it feel unique to you?
I know you haven't lived through this before,
but like
I don't know how to judge it.
All I know is that
I'm an adult now and I have to act like an adult,
whether whether I'm 17 or 18 I have committed like commitments that I make,
I have to go through with them and I've just,
my maturity,
I be forced to become mature.
Like I can no longer play video games and waste time.
There's things that I have to do but I've just been so blessed to find a solid
group of people who actually care about me and want the best for me.
Like like Ben and Charlie and Guy Benson,
people who have just reached out to me and I'm just selflessly helped me
navigate this political minefield.
But it's crazy cause like all the people that I looked up to like two years ago
and like would watch their videos,
I'm not going to snack.
Trying to like boost your ego here,
but I used to,
I would watch your show,
please consider it.
But yeah,
it's awesome that now I can reach out for their expertise.
The thing with me is that I always like to start with,
look,
I don't know anything and I,
I'm always looking to get more information to know more.
Like today I had a call with a gun expert,
um,
on the way here and it's like,
what more can I learn in order to be like fully fluent and knowledgeable about
the subject that I'm talking about?
And there are a bunch of stuff that I don't know about and I'm constantly trying
to learn.
So when you see a guy,
and again,
I don't like making this about people rather than ideas,
but when you see a guy like David Hogg out there and he clearly is taking just
the progressive line on this and he seems more to me to be sort of a progressive
activists than sort of a,
a fair arbiter of what's going on here.
Um,
that's gotta be frustrating for you that he's so public about this,
I suppose.
Well,
you obviously probably disagree with him on 100% of the policy parts.
This is true.
Yeah.
I don't want to make it about the personal part,
but that he's thought of as sort of a media hero and you're kind of the black
sheep of this group.
I mean maybe not to the,
to the Shapiros and me and whoever.
Yeah.
So here's what I say,
there was no issue that kids are on television.
The issue is,
is that when someone is spouting policy,
they are,
they are no longer a child.
They are pushing policy and they should be treated as every adult is such,
when you say something outrageous,
you should be called out on that.
I remember there's a segment with it.
It was on CNN where he said something completely outlandish.
Uh,
and there was no blowback solo careers.
Was that the line about Marco Rubio wants to kill kids?
That something crazy.
So what I say is when I'm pushing policy and I said I to do please like tell me
that I'm saying something stupid and pushed me back on that.
The thing is with me that I look,
when I'm on TV,
I'm not talking as a child and pushing policy.
Right.
And I expect there to be pushed back.
I don't think you can say whatever,
whatever you want.
Like I and in addition I think that having debate is great.
So like I love,
I love going on piers Morgan and having a debate with him.
That was great.
And I think we have to,
I hate this thing,
we're like we're,
we're one second you're spouting policy but then you rushed back to the shield
of,
Oh,
I'm a child but we have to take my opinion seriously because the second I say
that I'm an adult.
So just,
just this isn't,
this isn't fair.
And what I saw,
I think one of the reasons why,
um,
I grew to such publicity was because I was saying the things that adults weren't
able to say.
Like I was able to see things that Ben Shapiro or you or Charlie Kirk or the
right wasn't able to say because I'm a kid and I don't think that's fair because
I think that when you're sprouting policy,
you are no longer a child.
You are an adult.
What do you make of what's going on with the right generally because you ran the
turning point.
Was that the high school event that I did or I've done so many bicycling.
You,
okay,
so you did the high school leadership summit in DC and I spoke there,
this is a couple of months ago,
and you had a great lineup of speakers and Peter Teal was there and you had big,
big time politicians and,
and first of all,
I mean that was the first time we met and I was like,
holy debate about abortion,
that abortion is accurate.
So that's my point.
So first of all,
you,
you ran this whole thing.
I mean you're,
you're,
you're still in high school,
right?
We're going to talk a little bit about where you want to go to college and all
that,
but you ran an incredible event with major prime time people and and it was,
it was jam packed and it was diverse in terms of ideas.
So we get into a private debate about abortion,
but you brought me there and I went up there.
Thanks.
But I went up there and I talked about my differences with this group.
I talked about the kids were respectful and I talked about gay marriage and
abortion and death penalty in a couple of other things that generally these
young conservatives are not for.
I think gay marriage there pretty much for,
I like that the ship has sailed on that one actually.
I'm pretty sure I've got a huge ovation on that.
Um,
but it is just clear to me that there has been a real alignment on the right
where there is exactly what you're talking about or special about it.
Yeah.
Can we just say that Lindsey Graham 2.0 is fantastic.
No,
the guy,
it's unbelievable that,
I mean just that one,
the thing with the tie the any day,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Then he's doing great
daily caller.
Right?
So I
think the rightest finally realizing that youth,
um,
and like energizing the youth and instilling the next like future of
conservative leaders is important.
And we saw that with the high schoolers from something.
We had some of the biggest names speak like Nikki Haley.
Hey Betsy device.
We'd like,
oh,
attorney Jeff sessions.
We had so many people.
Um,
and every week we had Mark Meadows,
we had Steve Scully's,
we had,
we had Prager,
we need you.
Um,
and it was just,
it was fantastic to see the right.
Just understand that these are the leaders of tomorrow,
let's inform them.
But in addition,
turning,
put his such a great organization,
it's free speech,
free markets and capitalism.
Those are the three legs.
Uh,
and what we saw with turning point is such a,
it's such a great organization because we were,
we brought people who I have disagreements with to speak there.
Mark Cuban spoke,
got us a couple standing ovations,
had a debate with Charlie and people loved it.
So we're all open having free discussion and debate like we're,
we're,
we're working on Sassal shooting action summit December,
1920 second shameless plug.
And we're,
we're looking like how can we get the most diverse group of people to speak?
Like I'm thinking about somebody from the intellectual dark web to speak there.
I think it's great if we can get Alan Dershowitz just how can we get diversity
of thought?
So why is it that these new right or whatever you want to call it,
young conservative
group,
whatever it is,
why is it that you guys are able to do this?
And I see virtually none of this
on your counterparts on the left.
That's not sure.
I mean the left has organized and mobilize youth dish right now.
We are,
well,
I mean,
no,
but I'm talking about diversity of thought.
Like where are they bickering in people that's even mildly disagree with it.
I'm not talking about scary conservatives.
I'm talking about old school liberals where,
where are they inviting them to?
Just have an interesting conversation,
just so dead set on political correctness and sang everything to not offend
anyone with the slightest micro micro micro aggression that is just,
you can't live in that world and tall like logical liberals like yourself are
moving to the right.
I like these,
uh,
these subtle little injections of pleasantry.
Yeah,
that's nice.
Are moving people to the right and conservatives are like,
come here.
My refugees,
my political refugees were embracing you.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So when I hear people will say,
Ruben,
the conservatives are just using you.
You go to turning point,
they're just using you.
You're not just using me,
Kyle.
No,
I mean,
yeah,
but no,
no,
but really,
I mean what I've seen is intellectual flexibility there and it's,
even when I've had been in here and we've done this conversation repeatedly now
about gay marriage,
I just firmly believe that as time goes on,
I can shift him.
There's something that's sort of insulting about it to me.
When people say that to me because I'm confident,
I'm confident enough in my thoughts,
take you on abortion.
I really think that like in a few years you'll be with us on the board.
Maybe.
But you know what,
that would be a trade off,
right?
Like if,
if,
ultimately I always described myself as begrudgingly nation
of,
of homosexuality.
While I don't,
I don't,
I don't have a opinion on it because I haven't thought about it enough.
By his religious standpoint.
It makes sense.
But from the government standpoint,
it also makes total sense.
Well,
that's why I'm completely fine with him.
It's like you want to have your religious view.
I have to respect that.
But if you are trying to legislate my life,
the great thing with the right is that we're okay,
but you're just diversity of thought.
Just say whatever you want.
Let's talk about it.
And let's get to the right rational viewpoint.
Like I've,
I've always been about the bait because it brings people,
it's all about logic and it brings people to the right end result.
So when I'm on tour with Peterson,
uh,
the question that I think both of us get asked more than anything else is what
are the best techniques to wake people up out of this sort of postmodern
identity politics,
progressive group.
Think as a young person in the midst of this,
what would you say are some techniques you've been able to use?
Because it can't just be about drubbing them with facts,
right?
I mean the left is doing a fantastic job where they're just craziness and
pushing people to the right.
So there's just sort of stands for doing that on themself.
What we saw right now with Kanye and in addition,
it's just,
he was simply saying freedom of expression,
freedom of thought.
I support the president.
Our president has to be the freshest,
the flyers stuff,
the greatest lie.
I'm just pushing people to diversity of thought and freedom of expression to
think whatever you want and you shouldn't have,
you shouldn't be held down by your skin color or your race or your sexuality.
Like none of this matters.
You should be able to think what you want and be able to say it without being
tied down by you know,
your identity.
Yeah.
How do you make sure that you don't get burned out?
Because I think I remember the first communication we ever had.
I think when either you followed me or I followed you on Twitter.
I just sent you a quick one line note and I was just like,
just don't get burned out because I saw you just,
you were in the fight every day.
You were,
you were owning,
owning the libs and all that.
Which by the way,
you know you mentioned that Nikki Haley was at your summit.
It's like she went,
she went to to,
you know,
in effect what is a,
a lot of Trump people right at this,
at this event you put on,
she goes there and she says,
you know,
don't make this about just owning the libs and she got applause for it.
And I hit that same point I think the next day because I think if you guys do
exactly what you just laid out,
just kind of stand there and be cool and BBC,
you'll,
you will welcome a lot of people.
I think.
I honestly believe that the Cincy wins.
Can we just take a second and say,
Nikki Haley is fantastic and I,
I,
I kind of cried for like a week.
Right?
Ever since she said that.
Well,
do you think that this is perhaps a paving the road for her running at some
point?
I don't know.
There were so many 40 chess like theories.
I just know,
I just,
I know that she's just been doing a fantastic job and she's just one of the
best.
I Know Nikki Haley,
Ben Shapiro,
yeah,
I mean I'd probably have to be press secretary at that point.
Yeah,
that would work for like one horrific week and then I know that'd be fine.
I should do.
No,
but all right,
so gimme gimme some of the techniques when you see that it can't just be about
standing still and,
and facts,
if you're,
if you're
in a conversation with a young person that's really just bought into all of
this,
what are some of the techniques you use towards,
have you been successful?
I suspect that,
yeah,
I think I have,
but the first thing you have to realize is that is this person looking,
tapping open discussion and actually wants,
sorry about that.
Talking a lot these days.
It's all right or,
or actually wants to develop their point of view.
If they do,
you have to treat it with decency and respect and not calling them an idiot or
something.
Can you have to treat them like a,
like a good human being should,
um,
and then just have a rational conversation with them and see where they're
coming from.
Uh,
and a lot of times I can immediately know what they're going to respond to me.
Like just straight up the VAT.
I know what they're gonna respond to me and I hit them with,
with an initial,
here's what you're gonna say,
here's the reason.
And they're just shocked.
But then do you get them around?
I mean,
do you find,
cause it really,
it's like sort of deprogramming somebody out of this and I've had some success
at it.
Right.
And then a lot of them have watched my show now.
So yeah.
I mean when I first heard speaking out,
kids would come up to me in school in two things.
They would say,
it'd be like,
Kyle,
I'm a conservative.
So,
so the thing about school is really interesting.
I would get stare downs and like people like,
like try to beat me up so people would like send me like,
hey Kyle,
watch out.
So and so I was trying to beat you up.
I was like,
all right man,
go for it.
Um,
and people would give me stare downs and it was such and villainization of being
conservative and being second amendment somewhere.
When I spoke up,
I kind of opened the crack for people to say,
Oh,
I agree with him.
People would walk up to me and like hush up.
Like,
Kyle,
thank you so much for doing.
I'm just scared to speak out.
In addition,
people say,
Kyle,
I thought I was programmed control and you spoke and I listened to you and then
I did some more research and I agree with you.
So that was great to see.
And like that's just,
that's all I'm here for.
So like to have people you know,
understand conservatism and understand the second amendment,
it's gotta be pretty weird that you guys are still in high school,
right?
Like now you're your celebrities in the most strange sense of celebrity you are
and you're all still in high school together.
What is that like?
I mean,
at the end of the day we have to remember that we're kids and I will explain it
to her.
So you guys don't think I'm hypocritical.
Um,
when you're on TV and you're spouting politics,
you're an adult,
but in your private life you're a kid and we cannot forget that.
So let's say,
you know,
when someone,
some kid on the left does something stupid.
It's at the end of the day,
they're a kid and we have to address it at such.
Um,
but,
but it's,
it's been a crazy whirlwind and I think thank God I found a solid group of
people who want the best for me that I can reach out,
you know,
just not for policy but also like personal advice.
Like I,
I,
uh,
I asked Ben,
Hey,
how do you think I should approach college app since I'm a conservative,
you know,
and he helped me out and it's just,
it's so great to be able to reach out to people and have them,
you know,
give you advice from like look 20 years older than me and giving me that advice
that they had to go through.
Yeah.
What was that great tweet?
So you're like number one in your class,
right?
Not like number one,
you are number one.
Is that correct?
There was some tweet that you had about that.
Awesome.
What was that
number one?
Yeah.
Um,
and people got so angry cause so angry and they're like,
we're going to boycott graduation.
So I was like,
Yay.
More cake.
It was great.
And it was great.
And then,
you know,
the s the next semester,
what was the reason they wanted to boycott Greg?
I was number one.
Right,
right,
right.
So then the semester updated and then I was still number one because I posted
another tweet about that and then also blew up and I was like,
we're going to get Ben Shapiro to calm.
Dana Lash is going to come.
It's going to be fantastic.
Chris Cox was like,
yeah,
I'm going to be there.
Well,
why would they want,
I mean is that really how sort of polarizing Lee crazy this has got yes.
At a high school level that just because they don't like,
I mean you're your number one not by,
by being ordained no.
Onto you.
You're number one out of clearly a lot of hard work and smarts and all that.
You'd think that there would be certain respect for that
in some alternate universe.
But it's sad that we have,
we are no longer able to be friends with people.
Like it's sad that people on the left think so.
People on the left think that you're a Republican,
therefore you're evil.
And that sad that you're not allowed to be friends with people who have
different political viewpoints and you're like,
my best friend is a liberal.
And I actually brought him to the turning point event and after he was like,
you know,
Kyle,
some off some people made some good points and I was like,
yeah,
I told you,
he's still liberal.
He's an old school.
That's cool.
He's probably forgetting there.
You and him both.
Um,
all right.
So wait,
let's talk a little bit about college.
Okay.
So you're,
you're doing a great job in high school,
clearly.
Now you've got a public profile.
Grades are great.
Seemingly you could get in to wherever you want to go and try and do it.
Yeah.
So do you really think that that'll play a role in the schools that you're able
to get into?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's sad to say,
but,
but there is a bias against conservatives,
especially like the top tier schools.
Like right now I'm looking to apply to ivy's.
It'd be great to get into Harvard or Columbia.
Um,
I really think I,
man,
you'd be the reckoning of those places.
I really think that'd be awesome.
I really think,
I think it's really important to be accredited.
Um,
you know,
I might been thinking about Georgetown or Gw to work on the hill.
I think that's great.
Um,
but you know,
I really,
I really don't know what's next for me.
I really don't know.
It's got to go to college.
I'm definitely going to stay with turning point.
It's a great organization.
I'm still going to be conservative with,
don't worry,
I'm not going to change.
Generally people don't go the other way.
Right.
You're not going to suddenly grow up and be like,
Nah,
Nah.
I'll go to the feelings.
Things that usually does,
I won't happen.
Yeah.
But all right,
so you want to go to school,
but you,
so you really do think that your,
your politics could affect,
I guess,
you know,
they don't,
well,
what happened with David Hogg,
right?
He didn't get into all,
I don't know what his grades are,
but like he didn't get into a whole bunch of schools.
Right,
right.
I mean there've been rumors that had gone to Harvard,
northeastern,
it wouldn't surprise me.
Yeah.
And what do you want to study?
You have any idea?
It's either business or law.
I really don't know yet.
I just,
you know,
I,
I've always liked business and I think law is just absolutely phenomenal.
Really don't know yet.
Uh,
but you know,
it's going to be great to be on a college campus where,
you know,
everyone is just really liberal.
That'll be fun.
It's sort of weird and I guess this shows a little bit about the way the college
experience is,
is going,
but in a bizarre way,
just knowing you from the little bit that I know you,
it's like in a way it's almost like you don't have to go to college.
Like you definitely going to call.
Well,
I'm not saying you shouldn't.
And I think there's all sorts of social reasons that somebody should go and you
can,
you know,
you learn and all sorts of other ways that aren't necessarily academic,
but it's like,
clearly you've got the academic thing down and can keep learning that way.
So it's,
you know,
it's bizarre that people spend,
20 grand a year to go to college when no one thing is,
we're surrounded by a lot of great minds is what I'm saying saying I'm with you.
But the issue with colleges that you're basically paying to get yourself
brainwashed with stupidity and that's suck part because there were actual like
great things to learn in college.
Just not like lesbian dance theory that says that a lot.
Just some of these classes are just useless and you know,
and just,
it's just straight up complete stupidity.
A lot of the stuff that they're teaching there.
So what do you make of how this seems to be a through line through education and
I mean high school education,
college education,
clearly the media,
like all of this sort of brainwashing stuff that you're talking about.
It's always going against people like you.
And I see you on Twitter,
you,
you take down CNN all the time,
you take down main street videos.
People know my thoughts on this.
It's like I just wish like to me,
if these are,
we just addressed that Twitter,
just Twitter's for fun.
We have to stop taking Twitter.
So,
so like your bio,
your bio is perfect.
Twitter's not real life.
It's not real life but peep.
But the weird thing about that is it's starting to leak into real life.
I,
I did a direct message like a year and a half ago or so about how online culture
is becoming mainstream culture and I think that that really is what's happening
here.
Twitter is not real life,
but it's starting to like leak out into everyone's conversation.
So Fox News and CNN and MSNBC or basically Trump's Twitter,
like Twitter is like,
you know like have you seen shows where they basically read random replies to
messages?
It's like John Smith,
3.74 belongs to this like that.
And he was just so stupid.
But the biggest thing that we're seeing right now is,
is a cultural shift with the youth.
Like memes.
Memes have so much power and I was mad memes.
One,
a lot of memes helped so much for the trumps 2016 campaign with it really did.
Um,
and social media has a huge influence on our beliefs and our actions and that's
why it is so scary to see censorship of Conservatives online because that is
basically like Twitter is basically the new version of you just yelling into a
crowd.
Yeah.
And that's basically like the main form of everyone's communication and shutting
that down.
It's like heavily restricting,
you know,
I haven't developed my full opinion on this,
but it seems as such,
restricting this restricts your,
like really restricts your First Amendment,
right?
Yeah.
So this is the whole issue about whether they're publishers or platforms.
The big issue,
I don't know if I'm saying this right,
but I think one of the things is if there are certain,
if there are,
if there are published further than,
like they have a lot of legal liability.
If they're a platform,
then everyone should say whatever they want,
but that's not the case.
So it's like pick one
and they're just completely censoring,
uh,
conservatives.
Like,
I know Prager u gets like their videos demonetize so much.
And have you video has gotten to monetize?
They probably,
yeah.
Well,
like now,
now it's gotten a little bit better,
but our video is just don't go out to feeds anymore.
I went on that Craig,
and they don't dry out.
So rhythms.
Yeah,
that crazy rampage I went on where I just started retweeting real people.
I only did it with real people with real names saying they've been unsubscribed
and they're getting hundreds and sometimes thousands of retweets and I'm tagging
youtube and they just ignore me.
And it's like,
come on guys,
you gotta play this game a little bit better.
Facebook and Twitter all
have proven biases.
Proven.
Yeah.
How worried are a,
we'll say it's only interesting to me because you,
you never,
you didn't grow up in a time when there was some sort of trustworthy,
seemingly trustworthy level of the media.
Like CNN was not always this.
The reason,
I don't even know if you know this,
but the reason I think that so many people like me that are older than you
attack CN and the most is Cassina and used to be decent like MSNBC saying we
lean left
and CNN saying that and it's like no you're not.
We know exactly what you're doing.
And that's why I always tax CNN cause it's like you guys have actually become
the worst in the name of the ratings are like oh
they were like the lowest.
It's like a block or read CNN.
Yeah.
So here's what I think.
I think that a lot of young people and like Ma an average Americans do not trust
the media anymore and they have sought out individuals instead.
So they trust individuals.
So they look to you,
they look to Ben,
they,
they look to Guy Benson,
you know Charlie Kirk for,
for their news because they trust the individual.
Right.
Do you see a great risk in that too?
Cause I'm worried about it.
No.
I also put,
but the thing is with that is that you have absolute liability for what you say.
You know,
CNN can come whip something up or you know,
but when,
when an individual like tweets something it's on like they're responsible for
their actions.
Yeah.
So one of the things I've been saying lately is that I'm actually in a bizarre
way less interested in politics now than I've ever been,
but I'm interested in what you referenced a little while ago,
this culture thing,
culture,
where does it cultures,
politics is downstream from culture.
Yeah.
That's so true.
So do you see that really as,
as sort of the of all this that it's not going to be about all of the little
machinations of politics,
it's just going to be about,
I mean this,
I guess this is the strength of Trump.
Well,
where you'd argue it's either the strength or the,
the the worst part of Trump.
I suppose that is a cultural thing.
Not necessarily a political thing.
No,
I mean there,
there are pros and cons to that,
but we just,
we have to play by the rules that are set by society and these are the rules,
these little rules,
that culture has a massive impact on society.
And whether I like it or not,
that Kanye is Kanye speaking out.
First of all,
I think it's great that be speaking out to the First Amendment right.
I don't think we should be propping up opinions by celebrities simply because
they're famous.
You have to show that you are informed on the subject and that's that.
But it doesn't take a political genius to say that I believe in our second
amendment and our first amendment that doesn't take,
but Taylor swift doing like a 7,000 page essay,
you know,
that makes absolutely no sense and contradicts itself written by like a liberal,
a worker on the hill.
That's,
yeah,
I was disappointed in that just because I have no particular feelings about her
when I don't care.
I honestly,
I don't think I could name one song or whatever,
but it's just like the fact that she stayed out of politics I liked,
I was like,
oh,
whatever she's doing or whatever her handlers are saying to her.
I kind of like it.
And then she got in on this and it's like I don't care which way she was going
to break.
I was just like,
ah,
we just,
this is not what we need.
Yeah.
I mean,
Taylor swift effect president is like down Marsha Blackburn above.
So thanks Taylor swift.
No,
but,
but w w we saw right now by the left is that they are losing their stranglehold
on culture and that is very frightening for them.
And we saw that with Connie and Connie started speaking out,
I gave my speech about this and they started off with mob tactics that didn't
work.
Uh,
emotional appeal.
The teams,
he guy was basically begging him like,
Kanye,
please man,
take,
take off your hat,
man.
It hurts me emotionally because I was like,
no,
it's my first own right.
I'm not taking it off.
And then we saw I'm just blatant racism.
Yeah.
File a character.
Assassinations and he's still [inaudible].
You wouldn't that,
that,
that is,
how does that fly?
He wouldn't bow down to the mob.
Absolutely.
What input,
but no,
they're losing their stranglehold on culture and whether I like that we are
putting so much emphasis on my cultural icon,
those are the rules.
Them.
The rule is like they say that on Twitter a lot,
their rules.
Um,
but this is,
this is,
this is the reality that we're living in and we have to understand that.
And what's happening with Kanye is a real shift,
especially for African Americans and people who are looking a little tinos.
They're basically saying,
I don't know why this controversial Blackstone have to be Democrats.
You don't own me.
That's all there is.
Basically that's all he's saying.
And he has created such like a pivotal moment that says you're,
you don't,
you're stranglehold doesn't affect me.
Cause I know in Hollywood like the second you say something like,
I remember someone said bench murals are nice guy.
His career was
droid.
Mark Duplass who's a friend of mine,
he's been on his show and he had to issue an apology and it's like,
you know,
oddly whereas the world,
the idea of people,
people came to his defense at first basically saying,
you know,
you should be allowed to say that.
And then unfortunately
black and black,
especially young blacks are saying,
look,
they look up to Kanye West.
They millions look up to him and they say,
this individual,
why does this individual think this way?
And even more so he didn't bow down to the mob,
which is fantastic.
And we're seeing like a real shift.
I don't know the 38% number,
we're 38% African American approval over Trump.
I don't know if that's necessarily true.
All I know is that there was a 3% jump from there in August.
The black approval rating of Trump was 3% one of the last latest polls that I
know month or so ago was 10% so there is a big jump.
Uh,
you know what?
We're seeing that so many young African Americans are so energized.
Like I know turning point is doing a black leadership summit and like a week and
the White House,
we're going to get just 400 African American young individuals to be able to
speak their two times table,
listen.
And to see that the left is losing their stranglehold on culture.
And it is scary for them because that is the one thing that they have left.
All right.
I got two more for you.
You,
are you in the prediction game at all?
What do you think's going to happen in these midterms?
We've got coming up.
So what I've been hearing is that
Republicans are to lose it in the house and gain in the Senate.
Uh,
I love how a cause your work has,
is that we're going to win back the executive.
Yeah.
These midterms.
I was like
very confused about a lot
close.
Yeah.
But look,
the Cavenaugh effect is real.
Like this was like the,
all the left had to do was sit down,
be quiet,
be civil plaintiffs to like,
no,
this is,
we're not gonna allow this.
Okay.
And they hit themselves in the foot with the club and then there started crying
and they did the same thing with Connie and that was great.
So the Cavenaugh really amped up and energized the conservative base.
And even more so,
it finally gave the conservative,
like the conservatives a backbone,
like Lindsey Graham,
Lindsey Graham 2.0 or is this Guy Ben.
I love it.
And like bill Cassidy.
But,
but here's the peers.
The interesting thing.
Women were the most angered by all of this.
Before the cabin in August,
it was like 35.7% approval of Trump after it was a 40.7 and the F in August,
um,
Democrats at a 12 point lead over republicans in a voter enthusiasm.
Now it's 64% republicans,
65 Democrats.
So we are neck and neck in this and it's all thanks to the Democrats.
Yeah,
I mean my gut,
as long as you're doing predictions here,
I actually think the Republicans or do well in both the house and the Senate.
I really hope so.
But I do think so because I agree.
I think this mob mentality and watching these videos of Antifa and Portland and
Hillary saying we can't be civil and Eric Holder saying go low.
We them them and
it's like,
man,
if you stand for due process and civil society and all of those things,
that thing needs to burn it.
It kind of sucks,
but it's like that,
that set of ideas thinks the left just completely disregards the constitution.
The constitution was written and like the amendment,
the bill of rights was forced by anti federalists to make sure that the
government could not become tyrannical and abuse its power.
And this is so important and it's protecting the rights of the individuals in
these rights.
Why or why do we not all agree on them?
Why is it wrong to believe new process?
Why is it wrong to say I believe that individuals should have the right to
defend themselves and also defend against the tyranny of a possible government?
Look,
second man was basically written because the founders had just fought against
Great Britain and they had seen how a tyrannical government quickly become.
So one more thing I didn't know.
The first thing tyrannical governments do is they take away the weapons of the
civilians.
So I was in Nazi Germany,
we saw this in China,
we saw this in,
in Cambodia.
That's the first thing they do.
Uh,
and the individual right to bear arms is,
is every individual is not related to the militia clause.
So it's basically saying every individual has the right to protect themselves
and even more so it's,
it's necessary for the protection of a free state.
All right,
one more for you.
Hit me with,
they don't play video games as much.
I know cause you don't have time.
What do you do for fun,
man?
What's fun?
I used to sites.
Twitter.
You can't just tell them to Twitter.
I know you're having put on a computer,
but it can't just be Twitter.
What are you doing for fun with me?
I used to play a lot of video games.
What kind of game?
So here's,
here's my progression.
I haven't said this,
but this is like a scoop.
I used to play world of tanks.
Okay.
Advent moved to to a rocket league.
It's sockets.
Terrible game.
It's boring.
Then it moved to,
so I played Overwatch.
I played Paladins,
I played pub g and then I played for night and four,
nine.
This was when the shooting occurred and I just stopped dead in my tracks because
it was just,
it's a waste of time.
And I see my younger brothers who were addicted to the game and it's just sad to
see that this is the state of our youth,
that they're just completely addicted to technology.
Like I'm sure if I have kids,
okay,
they're not saying a phone till they're 12.
It even if they do call me or nine one,
one that's no video games.
You're reading a book.
I don't care.
So what do you do for fun?
You just [inaudible] you told me what you're used to do.
Okay.
Come on.
You must be having fun somewhere.
You're having fun sometimes.
Wow,
I got you.
Yeah man you did.
No,
but you're,
you are having fun with this.
I actually have some of some of the remaining friends that I have,
uh,
which are really solid friends.
You know,
on weekends we hang out a,
we'd go watch movies and stuff like that.
In addition,
I,
I just think it's great.
One of the greatest things for me for having fun is just simply talking to like
minded kids,
like young individuals at these turning point events that we run and it's great.
And like meeting with and pushing policy and stuff like that.
It's just fantastic.
Like one of the greatest feelings ever was like passing the Stop School Violence
Act and fix the Knicks like the stops,
Galvan Sec,
um,
appropriated funds $2 billion in,
for the protection of schools like hardening schools,
metal detectors are making better communication for law enforcement,
training,
law enforcement teachers and students.
And in addition,
there was a clause that said none of this money will be used for firearm,
a firearm trainings.
So this was like the greatest win for the left and they still hate it,
the bill.
And like the march for life,
kids hated it.
But no,
I mean I'm really dead set on making sure that school shootings just are a thing
of the past.
They never happen again.
Uh,
and you love what you do,
man.
Yeah,
It's just like,
just learning about second amendment and just like being more knowledgeable and
having these debates and discussions are just like,
they really make my day.
Yeah.
Well I think it goes without saying.
I mean,
I think you have an absurdly bright future.
Thank you.
You're like,
you're going to run for president or something.
Probably not,
but you left a little window.
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
I literally do.
Maybe there's a thing,
um,
for politics like the hill in the future.
Right now,
I'm just dead set on going to college,
getting my degree,
learning,
uh,
staying the political sphere.
But,
uh,
you know,
who knows.
I'm definitely supporting Nikki Haley's Shapiro 2024 ago.
Right.
You see people there is hope for the future.
For more on Kyle,
follow him on Twitter at Kyle [inaudible].